of all her royal engagements this was
the one the duchess of sussex spoke of
most
fondly it was her first solo engagement
with the queen
they took the royal train to the north
west of england
megan describing the day as full of
wonderful kind
moments shared with the monarch
the north of england feels worlds apart
from the couple's new lifestyle in los
angeles and although this part of the
world might not have
palm trees or sun-drenched patios a lot
of the issues discussed
in that interview with oprah have really
hit home here
especially that of race i think it's
fairly unsurprising uh to me maybe uh
as someone who's not white that
conversations were had
in a royal household about the color of
the baby's skin it says something about
the institutions that are in place
and the higher powers that be that this
has come to be expected
and that we're no longer shocked harry
megan's interview was about their royal
life but the
issues they raised have divided public
opinion
a yougov poll asked people across great
britain
when it comes to the dispute with whom
does your sympathies mostly lie
48 of under 24 year olds said harry and
megan
just 15 of that age group said the royal
family
it was good to good to see someone go
out and be honest and i think it was
brutally honest
i think that the royal family did them
wrong and
they should have had more support than
they did have it sounds like megan
really was silenced
but more than half of over 65s polled
supported the queen and royal family
even if they thought the couple were
right to speak out
i think their way of doing it was not to
put their royal family down it was more
of like
let people know what's going on i don't
think they did i don't think they did it
maliciously
i mean they wanted to keep out the
landline that's what's annoyed me more
and yet they're giving all these
interviews
so you can't have it both ways can you
i think she's uh very much still an
actress
and that's she seems to be playing a
part
across the country there was also a
split by political view
the poll found conservative voters were
much more likely to sympathise with the
royal family
but also there were many people who
simply didn't care
like billy it's it's not relevant the
way the world is at the moment is it i
mean the world's in turmoil he's picked
these
thousands of people dying you know
hundreds of thousands of people have
lost their lives in our land
why should anybody be woody what what
two people in america say
a divided family a divisive interview
if the couple wanted closure they've not
found it here
catherine of autopsy sky news in
manchester